deshidratados sin suficientes
medicamentos ni médicos que los atiendan
esos haitianos son víctimas del último
brote de cólera en el país que se
produce trazos disturbios sociales y la
violencia de las pandillas en la última
semana va el número de infecciones de
cólera se ha disparado con más de 100
casos sospechosos
a principios de esta semana más de 20
pacientes fueron admitidos con
infecciones de cólera por día
desgraciadamente el miércoles pasado dos
de los pacientes con cólera murieron
pero el acceso a los servicios básicos
necesarios para tratar el cólera como el
agua potable y los medicamentos se ha
interrumpido desde mediados de
septiembre bandas armadas están
bloqueando la principal terminal de
importación de combustible de Haití lo
que ha provocado una escasez de agua
embotellada casi diesel como resultado
la ayuda internacional no puede entrar y
la falta de combustible significa que
los camiones de agua no pueden llegar a
los barrios y los hospitales se ven
obligados mantener sus operaciones las
Naciones Unidas han solicitado la
creación de un corredor humanitario para
ayudar a satisfacer las necesidades
urgentes de la población
muy preocupante ha sido la interrupción
de la distribución de agua
y como todos sabemos en esta sala el
agua limpia Es realmente una de las
condiciones reales para contener un
brote de cólera
y para salvar vidas durante un brote de
cólera
se están realizando pruebas para
determinar si esta cepa de cólera es la
misma que mató a más de 10.000 personas
entre 2010 y 2019